It's time for Drew's News,
your daily tune up at the good news garage, vroom vroom,
and today I've got two fantastic mechanics
under that news hood with me.
She's a best-selling author, a fearless journalist
and a hero of mine, Lisa Ling.
Thank you, really?
Oh yeah, oh yeah.
Thank you.
And he helps me make the good news engine go
every day of the week, it's Rossi Ross Matthew.
Hi everybody, we have Lisa Ling.
We have like, a real newsmaker.
We're both dorking out over Lisa Ling,
I love you.
Oh you guys, thank you.
It's a really big deal.
Thank you, I appreciate it.
I'm so excited to be here.
I've always been a good news junkie.
I mean, I am like, I do my civic duty.
I watch that news every single day.
Same.
Yeah, I mean for me, I, I, I wanted to be on TV as a kid
and I, and I'll tell you why.
So, my parents got a divorce when I was seven
and they were working all the time
and the TV was always on in my house.
We didn't have a lot of money
and so I thought, well, if I can somehow get a job on TV,
maybe one day I can have a better life,
but no one looked like me on TV.
You know, like, my favorite show was The Brady Bunch,
and I didn't look like Jan or Marsha or,
but there was Connie Chung,
and do you, do you all remember Connie Chung?
Of course!
Love Connie Chung.
Yes, I mean, Connie Chung just symbolized
all that was intelligent
and beautiful and graceful,
and I, I, she allowed me to know that I could,
I could do this 'cause she was the
only Asian person on a national stage,
and if you ask any Asian journalists of my generation,
I'm sure they will all say that Connie Chung
was their inspiration 'cause she was the only one.
And think about this Lisa, like the next generation,
they see you, you know,
and they're looking at you
and they're gonna emulate what you're doing now.
Don't make me cry.
I know, I mean, Ross.
It's so cool of you.
Ross, I think that's the best point
that we have made so far.
Absolutely, you're so astute.
Thanks for saying that.
I appreciate that.
Well, we are so thrilled you're here.
We do like to get into some headlines.
So are you ready?
Let's do it, let's do it.
All right.
First up, we've got a fascinating fact
that we just learned about, well,
another hero of all of ours
and someone you worked intimately with, Oprah.
People reports that she recently went
on Hoda's podcast to reveal
that when it comes to friends, the magic number is three.
Oprah says she doesn't have a lot of friends.
It's just Gayle, Maria Shriver and her trainer, Bob Greene.
Lisa, what do you think about this
magic three number with your colleague Oprah?
Well, it's funny 'cause I did work
for Oprah for a long time,
and it was hard to imagine being friends with her
because I just, I was so in awe of her and I just,
I would just stare at her
and she would probably not wanna
be friends with someone like me,
'cause I was creeping her out.
Yeah.
All of my friends, I have more than three,
but they are 40, 30, and 20 years in the making.
So, they're really, I, I'm into old friends,
and I feel like, I don't often get
to make new friends necessarily.
What about you Rossi?
Well,
That means you by the way,
your my friend but I've known you for a long time too.
Sorta, yeah right?
But we became like, boom,
right when we needed each other.
Like velcro.
I know.
(audience laughing)
I looked at, I think this might be
the first time I've ever felt sorry for Oprah.
I think, I think I understand the value of
keeping a tight circle, but girl, it isn't,
do you need a friend, honey?
I'll take you out to happy hour,
my treat Oprah and I mean that from the bottom of my heart.
(audience clapping)
I just don't like, I count my friend,
they're so important to me and if I committed a crime,
I could think of 22 people off
the top of my head I would call,
who would lie to the authorities for me,
and you need that.
You're lucky, you're lucky.
My friends would be like, ah again,
you're in trouble again, like c'mon.
Oh Lisa Ling, I love you.
I already loved you.
By the way, seriously, like real talk though,
all jokes aside, I can't imagine
the places you have put yourself.
Have you ever truly been nervous,
in over your head or like,
whoa, what is next?
Yes (laughs)
Really?
You know, before I even started at The View,
I worked for a show called Channel One News,
which was seen in schools across the country,
and we were sent to cover some crazy things.
I mean, I covered the civil war in Afghanistan in 1994
and I covered drug wars throughout South America,
and I would say the scariest moment for me was when
we were repelling out of narco helicopters
with the narco police, into cocaine infested laboratories,
in the jungles and getting fired upon,
that was a kind of scary moment.
Maybe I need to work a lot harder
because I mean, I was scared one time when I grabbed like,
a pashmina at Macy's, with half off,
there's only one, give it to me.
That is the most dangerous thing I've ever encountered.
That is scary.
It was scary but I did get that pashmina,
thank you very much.
You know who you are.
In all transparency,
we have put Ross in some very perilous situations,
so many carbs, so many carbs I've forced you to eat.
Alright, Lisa, will you please take the next story.
Well, next up, we are turning to some sports news
and it's always a heartbreaker when an athlete
is sidelined by injury, but Mets star pitcher,
Noah Syndergaard, has found an incredible way
to make time count.
The New York Times reports, Noah, also known as Thor,
put down the baseball and picked up some books
and started his own book club.
He invited fans to join via text
and each month they get a new title
and take the conversation even deeper.
Noah interviews authors on Instagram Live.
Mets fans say it helps them appreciate
their pitcher in a new way
and some say they're reading books
they never would have picked up.
So, are you guys in a, in a book club?
I'm not in a book club,
but I really love the books that he's putting out there
because I always think when athletes talk about
mental health, these are infallible, incredible,
you know, humans with extraordinary capacity.
I love when tough guys come out and show their softer side.
This is a great gateway in that might not have the stigma
of you're weak or you're this, it's like,
even strongest people we know.
It's totally hot too, right?
Totally.
I mean,
Yes!
Guys who, you know,
in those like tight pitcher pants and also well-read,
I, that's like a perfect combination to me.
Totally.
That's, that's what we call,
that's what we call a home run, hey.
(everybody laughing)
Well, this story I really loved
because it spoke to me
and made me feel a little less alone.
Here is a question,
would you rather life be calm or exciting?
What would you say Ross?
I wonder.
I, I'm gonna go with calm now.
Wow.
Because back in the day,
it's like give me a little excitement
but now give me some elastic and some Netflix,
I'm exhausted.
(audience clapping)
Right?
And CNN actually report that a new study
found people overwhelmingly, prefer calm.
They surveyed people in 116 countries
and 72% wanted calm and 16% wanted exciting
with 10% wanting a mix of both.
So, I'd like to poll the audience right now,
grab your poles everybody,
and let's ask you guys with a show of green for calm,
being your desired lifestyle
and red for a hot, exciting lifestyle.
Okay, here we go.
Oh it's kind of a mix.
Interesting.
Oh, I like you're just right in the middle ma'am,
I might have to ask you,
what's the middle all about
and what does that mean to you?
I am a single mother,
so I'd like a calm life with my children,
but then I also want an exciting life
when I don't have them (laughs),
when they're with their dad.
(upbeat music)